so ikea 25 has just been released and it
has some incredible features
today i wanted to showcase how to use
archicad 25
and design a project from the very start
to the very finish
this video is basically going to be for
everybody who's just picking up be it
archicad 25
or archicad in general for the very
first time or
anybody that's been using arcad for a
very long period of time
i guarantee you'll learn something new
so let's get started
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me on this channel
here we talk about all things
architecture and technology
a little bit about myself i am a
registered architect here in the state
of western australia and i work
predominantly on archicad
so i have a very good understanding and
a very good working knowledge of
archicad especially arcade 24 and 25.
on this channel you will find some great
information about architecture
technology and archicad in general
and down below there's a number of links
including a discord chat where you can
join a growing community
of individuals and like-minded people
from all over the world be it students
architects or other industry
professionals that have
the same interests and share their
knowledge with each other
this community is rapidly growing and it
is fantastic to see
how quickly people are jumping on board
how much information is being
shared on that community and how helpful
everybody is
so if you're already a part of that
discord chat thank you for being a part
of it thank you for making it what it is
and
thank you for making it something so
truly meaningful
anyway enough of my rambling let's get
started with today's
intro into arcade 25 video by turning
around to these screens
okay so like always we're going to be
starting with the arcade 25
australian select template that's what's
available to me
but feel free to use whatever is
available to you
we're going to be making a relatively
simple project it's going to be
something like a one story home
um and we're just going to go through
the very basics of
archicad 25. so arcad 25 is laid out
exactly the same as most other archicads
are we have
our main control panel here on the left
hand side we have all our features at
the top which we'll run through later on
and we have our layers system here on
the right hand side what we want to do
in arcade 25 like we always do is start
by setting up our layers
start by clicking control or command and
the number seven
to bring up our story settings the story
settings are critical especially if you
start linking layers
it means you can go in and quickly
change adjust story heights
and your whole project adjusts with you
so if you set up everything correctly at
the start
it's very very simple to change later
down the track
so if for example you go from timber
frame to brick coursing and need to
change everything a couple millimeters
well it's very simple to do it you can
do it in here versus going through and
manually adjusting every single wall
so let's start by inserting a story
below and i'm going to call this
footings i'm going to go minus 172
millimeters because that is
the rough size for a good standard slab
with an edge thickening
our floor in itself is going to be a
timber frame so let's go 2745
which is two seven ceiling level plus
the plates we're not going to have a
first floor we are going to have a roof
so what i'm just going to simply do is
delete the first story and
leave the roof exposed now if we're
going to go for a concealed ceiling roof
it's probably going to need about 600
millimeters
or if we're going to go for something
like a concrete roof we might be able to
do it from about 150 to about 250
depending on how far we want to cancel
either so let's start by about 250 ml
for that roof we're going to do a
concrete roof design and hopefully not
cancel even too far that our engineer
wants to shoot us
so clicking okay we've deleted one story
which was that home story that's okay
we'll just go delete so over here on the
left hand side like on arcad 24 we have
our main control panel
this is your main organizer where every
single thing that you create will show
up and you will always be able to see it
here
if you go into this setting go show
organizer it's going to pop up
with a main display so if you do go
ahead and create some new sections some
new elevations
using it from the main organizer tool or
the view map
you're going to struggle to find them
until you literally click them and
drag them where they need to be now we
can close that and get out of that
and continue moving forward so you want
to be using the view map more often than
not and you want to be working through
these layers
if you do have your own template this
may look completely different but this
is the default
archicad template that is out and
available so let's start by
going on to the ground floor things
won't change we're already on the ground
floor and we're just going to create a
very simple design we're not going to go
too far complex we're just going to use
a little bit of brick a little bit of
concrete a little bit of glass we're
going to keep the theme very simple
maybe throw in a little bit of timber so
let's start simply
by working on our actual architecture
the first thing we want to do
is take the wall tool now wall tools
it is critical that you understand your
layer systems and why
that is important so if we take a look
at our layer system here it's on a walls
external
we have a million and one different
layers that we can take a look from
but we want to stick to walls external
for the time being
this setting here allows you to change
geometry to click multiple times
without having to do anything so i can
escape that
the second one allows you to create a
curved wall
we can escape that these are the main
two that you'll really be using at any
point in time
you can create curves even with this
straight geometry
but that's something we'll get into a
little bit later the outside face the
inside face or the center
dictates where the main line is so if i
zoom in you'll see the black line there
let's change that to the center it
changes where you're actually
clicking the walls from so i like to
start with the outside face because
we're drawing the outside of the wall
so we always know what the inside is you
can change that to however you see fit
or whatever your purpose is
so i know this video is going very very
fast and i'm trying to get as much
information here as possible
so feel free to pause this video go back
re-watch it watch it again until you
really
get a hang of what i'm trying to explain
if i do explain anything too fast i
apologize leave a comment down below and
i will go through it in more detail over
here we have our wall composite panels
and we have our structures
so we can adjust our composites to a
number of different ways
by default there is many custom walls
already set up in archicad 25.
now depending on your template will
depend on what you see here i'm
going to start with a 90 millimeter stud
partition that's going to be
my external wall you can use any of
these it doesn't really matter it
depends on your project personally so
let's start with a nice timber wall
we're probably going to create a nice
elongated design
we're not really going to focus on the
architecture too much it will look
pretty good at the end of it because
anything you do in arcade usually does
but we're predominantly focusing on how
the system works itself so clicking
our very first time allows us to
generate our first wall
as you see it is freely moving you can
do whatever you want
there are these snap grids that are
automatically activated on archicad 25
i personally don't like the snap grids
because they cause
a lot of more headaches than they do
actually help in any way shape or form
so let's escape out of that quickly go
to view and simply turn off snap guides
here
okay now let's click once again to start
that wall you see those snap guides are
gone
and all we have to do to get a perfectly
level wall is hold
the shift button so i'm gonna draw
something like a five meter
wall and i'm not going to go back and
drag slowly what i'm going to do is
continue to hold shift
press the d command and then type in
5000 that's going to create our very
first
wall and then i'm going to slowly drag
it back in
do the same shift d 3000
shift d 3000
shift d 3000 and let's go
shift d 20 000
and let's just return that back so shift
d
will go 10 meters run it all the way
back and you'll see
it clicks in line with this at 28 meters
go okay go
okay now as you see we've created our
almost box with a small little entry
point here it is a relatively simple and
easy structure that we've created if we
click once
highlight it all we can press ctrl d
to allow us to move anything that move
feature works with
one object all objects or anything that
you just want to simply move
now as you saw there i clicked once on
this wall
and it was all grouped because i drew it
as a polyline
if i wanted to ungroup this all i do is
click escape once
and then click alt g now if i click once
more you'll see
only one is activated if i press alt
g again it'll group all those items back
together
and activate that group per se so we can
actually utilize it now the best thing
about arcad 25 and
arcade in general is you can simply go
show all in 3d
and straight away we've already drawn
something
very cool without having to do too much
now if you do want to fly around like
that all i'm doing is holding shift
to create the orbit tool and the center
of my scroll wheel
by clicking down the scroll wheel you
get the pan function by holding shift
you get the orbit function
you can scroll in and out to zoom and
that's pretty much all the basics down
here there's this little man that lets
you explore so if you click
you're going to get this 3d information
that basically tells you how to operate
the system i don't want to say that
again
i know how to use it and then go 3d
explore basically it turns in
to a first person shooter video game if
you've ever played any of those
dot s is back w is forward a is left
d is right base is up and c is down
moving the mouse side to side up and
down moves it like a head
so if you wanted to move forward a
little bit faster holding shift
you can see we can start flying around
our project
just like we would in a video game so
this is a very useful way to fly around
the project if you're just trying to see
into one small specific feature
so if i wanted to take a look at this
corner i could fly into this corner very
easily
versus trying to actually figure out how
to get there by orbiting around and
zooming in going back to our ground
floor plan what we're going to do is
start manipulating the shape a little
bit more
extending it elaborating it moving it
and changing it so let's ungroup
everything by clicking alt
g again selecting these two walls here
and then i'm going to click on that
corner and go to the chamber or
fill it tool what i want to do is
actually curve that corner in
so let's go two meters and click ok
you'll see we've created a nice
beautiful curve right there on the entry
i'm going to do the exact same thing on
this side selecting those two walls
fill it two meters okay and there we go
we're now
entering into our building exactly as we
wanted to
now i do want to drag this a little bit
further in so let's go another
four meters and click these
two walls on the side now i could
individually click on one of these
select the stretch tool drag it all the
way up by holding shift to keep it dead
straight and clicking okay
or i could click the control i button
which will automatically group
everything so if i escape that and go
ctrl z z or control zz whatever country
you're in we can
undo what we just did so let's highlight
those three walls
click control i and it magically joins
them all together it is one of
my most used commands and if you didn't
know that one it's a good one to know
now i also want to do the same thing
over here with that two meter chamber
so we're creating a nice curved
elaborated edge on both of these sides i
don't really want this here
i do want it a little bit further over
so let's move that
two and a half across by using our shift
d and typing it in like we did before
now what you notice is if we try to
connect all of these at once by clicking
control
i or command i it fails to do it
properly
even if you do it again it will not
actually
join those walls correctly so what we
want to do is
only select two walls at once join them
select two walls at once
and join them if walls are intersecting
or the computer can get confused it's
not going to be able to do the job
properly now
moving on to the rest of this design
basically that's going to be a bedroom
that's going to be a master living
spaces
and things like that we're not worried
about proportions we're not worried
about any of that
we're just kind of worried about how to
use the program how the structure works
and what we're really going to get out
of it so what you'll see here
is if i select all these walls again go
up to my settings dialog box or press
ctrl t to open that up we can see that
our top story
is linked to our roof now like i said
before
it is at 2745 so if i come back into my
3d window
go control 7 let's say we need to change
that to three and a half meters for some
reason
press okay those walls will
automatically jump
up now i don't want that so i'll go back
into command seven
two seven four five click okay they'll
drop back down to the right height
so that is really critical that we set
up those story heights
and know what we're doing to be able to
better the project later on if anything
does change
coming back to the ground floor plan
let's start by introducing some doors
some windows
some different elements and some
different textures so
we're going to come across this palette
over here you see we have a whole bunch
of different
options on the left we have our wall
tool we have our wall end tool
doors windows etc let's start by going
into the door tool
clicking on the door itself and you'll
see we have a number of different
doors available in archicad 25. now i
have no idea what this design is going
to be so we're just really going to play
with it a little bit let's click on this
arched door to start if you click on the
front tool
you'll see that door in an elevation
view
if you click this little 3d box you'll
see in color
exactly what it's going to come out in
the 3d window so if we wanted to go
through and change bits and pieces we
can go through
all of our door settings so the door
height is probably a little bit too
short for me let's make it 2-4 which
increases that beautiful arch over there
the width the width is okay for me i'm
not a problem
the shape of it itself is okay i think
the
overall door height is fine as well i
don't want a grid on the door
i want it to be a nice solid timber door
moving through we know our frame sizes
that's not that important we know our
different styles if we wanted to add a
grid
if we wanted it to be solid we could
change it up here continuing through
if we wanted to add a handle arcade 25
has added a significant number of
new handles including the panic bars
which are really nice because
in commercial design you need to add
them quite often now let's select the
handle we'll just go random handle one
for now
is absolutely fine you'll see it pop up
straight away and then we can continue
going through our settings
and changing things how we like them so
if we don't like the colors of this we
can come into the model attributes
change the colors around so if we don't
want it to be wood let's say we want a
nice
black frame we want the frame inside to
also be black we want the leaf outside
to be black
we want the leaf inside to be black and
we want the leaf glass to stay as it is
that bits fine
the handle can stay as black that's not
an issue now what you'll see
is that the actual arch doorway didn't
change so if we continue going through
our settings we'll find
a secondary model attribute and then
also a third model attribute where we
can change
the settings of that outside so if we go
in there change that to black
all of a sudden our door frame is now
fully black with a glass door
so clicking ok where do we want to put
our door no
idea maybe we start somewhere over here
we'll flip it inside
and we'll move on to our window tool so
now the window tool works in a very very
similar way that the door tool does
there is a number of presets available
here on arcade25 that you can choose
from
you can have anything from a fixed to a
multi-hinge to a triple window
to all sorts of different patterns
whatever your heart really desires and
you can play with them as much as you
like
so if i wanted to introduce something a
little bit different we would start with
our fixed window arcade 25
let's drop that right in the middle not
worry about what it looks like what size
it is
go into 3d go to our little man fly
all the way over here and you can see
that window has come up quite nice
it's way too small let's say i want to
make that
the whole size of this wall so by
clicking on the edges selecting the
stretch tool
i can run it all the way across clicking
on the edges again selecting the stretch
vertically tool
i can go all the way through and drop it
to the bottom
now that window frame doesn't match our
beautiful arch window
nor is it in line so i'm going to drop
it to 2-4 there's going to be a little
bit of a head on it but that's ok
we're going to open up the settings and
work our way through very similar like
we did for the door looking at all sorts
of different options
we can have a grid with editable grid we
can have a divider
whatever really your heart desires
hinges as well
and then finally we're going to get to
our model attributes where we can go
through
and change that all to black like we did
change that to the clear
and now we have matching door frames
personally i hate this orange you guys
know i hate that orange
so we're going to open up those settings
again we're going to go to the overrides
because it is simply quicker to click
override pens
and go black rather than going through
every single thing
individually now you can do everything
individually
if you want different line types and
line weights for different elements
but for this purposes of this tutorial
i'm not really too fussed about line
weights pen types or anything like that
so now we have the beginning of our
beautiful
garden design here that we're working
from if we come back into our floor plan
you'll see our window has massively
increased by holding the alt button
and clicking once we can get our
eyedropper tool that eyedropper tool
basically replicates whatever we have
selected
so let's drop that window in over there
with the sun facing outwards
selecting where we want it to go shift
ctrl
d and dragging it in line with this
other window so what we've effectively
created
is a glass thoroughfare looking through
the house
and our arch door there on the side that
is the basic concept of
doors and windows it isn't actually too
hard at all to be able to go through
manipulate your doors and windows change
your doors and windows change your mind
you can have full freedom and creativity
here
so for the same reason we can click that
eyedropper tool
simply find the center of that wall drop
it in
and we have another picture frame window
here
let's say i definitely don't want that
to be that big i want it to sit a metre
off the ground
so i can go seal height to story zero
meter i only want that to be a very
linear window and
we want to make that about 800
millimeters
so it's this perfectly centered window
as a landscape picture frame window if
we wanted to duplicate that 3d we could
click on that
click control d click on one of the
corners and then click
control or command again holding shift
lets us move it up and down wherever we
want
and let's just drop it there so we've
created two
windows now if we don't want that window
simply click on it and
tap the delete button so as you can see
we're starting to get
some sort of architectural form
happening here and we're getting the
doors and windows and elements working
together
now let's say we wanted to make this
window different and not fixed so you
could actually get some air into this
house
so let's go okay command t let's start
changing up these settings
going into the basic window settings and
going back to the very start we can
start manipulating at how we see fit
let's say we wanted to make that a
sliding window for example we could come
over to our window settings and openings
we could change that main setting or the
main
sash to whatever we really wanted so
let's go sliding you'll see it creates a
sliding window
sliding mirrored does the exact same
thing on the other side
we could change that to a tilt turn it
would be a very large very heavy very
awkward window
but you have the option you can have a
bottom hung window
you can have a top hung window again the
options are basically limited
in your imagination so let's stick to
and not a
double sliding we'll stick to a single
sliding window
and click ok so as you can see
now we have one panel that slides one
panel that's fixed very typical
there are some other cool features here
that we can also utilize
our sunshades devices so i quite like
the sunshade devices because it allows
you
to really emphasize the look and
architecture of the building so
here we have a decorative we have a
regular we have a regular reveal
we have a folding to wall face we have
our sliding
and we have our rolling now every single
thing is different that's kind of like
your roller shutters
it is probably a bit too bulky a bit too
much i do
like the sliding ones in this option you
can have different positions
let's say left to right both slides to
one side
left to bottom bottom to right you can
change it however you see fit
probably a symmetrical one will look
quite nice on this one
you do also have a number of different
styles as well as a custom option
if you do want to go ahead and change
that let's say you're looking for like a
barn style architecture
you can go something here and change
that up completely
or if you don't like that you just
simply want a regular opening like we
had before
it also has that option there now if you
do want it to cover the windows
in your 3d you can drop that down to
1500 per se and it will slide halfway
over your windows
or you can drop it to zero and it will
slide all the way over your windows so
let's go 1500
see what that looks like it is way too
big
and does not work on our architecture at
all
because the main rail to cover it is too
large
so what we would do in that instance is
simply come into this
change that down to two and a half
instead of three
take a quick look still way too big so
let's again
drop that down two meters and now we
have a window that works
well so if we do want to open that up
two meters
we can see it fully open on the side of
our house
and have some sort of architectural
flair to it now let's go once more into
those command t settings
and start changing some model attributes
so in this fixtures and fittings we can
go down to model attributes
and we can change bits and pieces i
don't like the fact that it's stainless
steel for that rail let's make it black
but let's leave that timber as it is
so there as you see you have these nice
shutters and something that is a little
bit different to
the norm if we came back into our ground
floor plan we could then
hold the alt button to select our
eyedropper tool we could drop
three of those windows along this side
here
if we did want to move this window over
here let's say we drag it
over here and then we drag it to the
center
so that's about six meters apart we'll
drop it three meters in between
we'll see that those windows have
automatically been
replicated now that is horrendous from
an architectural point of view so i'll
quickly click all those three
delete them come back into our ground
floor plan
select our large window over here by
zooming in
holding the old button clicking once and
dropping it over here
what i do want to do instead of making a
large window
i want to make it a narrow window so
let's go 750 mil
by 2-4 coming back into our 3d gives us
a large
linear window now that window is going
to be
a little bit different from everything
else so let's duplicate that three times
what we're going to do is click on one
of these black dots
come over to our multiply tool let's
spread
about 1500 spacing between them
so if i hold once you'll see it as i
move 1500 centers it'll create one two
three windows so there we go we have
three linear windows over here that are
starting to create some architectural
form now if i wanted to edit all three
of these at once
select them all click command t and it
opens up the settings for all three
windows let's go into our
sun and shade tool once again click our
sun
shade and instead of decorative we're
going to go to regular so they're just
basically going to
flip inwards let's go 75 degrees and
they
start to close maybe 45 degrees they're
half
closed we're going to stick to the same
style that we had over there
and clicking ok so as you can see we've
created our shutters over these three
main windows
all folding at 45 degrees now if we
wanted to change that one over here
to maybe 180 degrees and
change this one over here to 75
90 degrees maybe we can really adjust
these however we see
fit you can also adjust them in 3d
by selecting the hotspots and dragging
them wherever you see best fit so if we
move them around
or we can simply just start typing in 45
again and it will reset that
so once again clicking that hotspot
dragging in 45
and it's back to where we had it before
now the beginning of our house is
starting to look pretty good we have
the general fundamental basics of the
archicad 25 here what we can do
is go back into our ground floor and one
of the best and newest features of
arcade 25
is right clicking on something scrolling
down and go
select in 3d now that feature wasn't
available in arcade 24 before or any
other arcade
and you can see it automatically jumped
to that specific
element in 3d it works the same exact
way
in 3d going back to 2d so right clicking
scrolling down select on floor plan and
there we go
it is automatically jumped to that
specific window
in the 2d floor plan i know exactly what
i'm looking at
so a quick little interlude here if you
guys are struggling with your
architectural drawings and you're
looking at a way
to make them better either being at
sketch design stage or construction
phase stage
there is a link to some digital
downloads down below
which contain a sketch design and a
construction checklist
this is by far the most popular item i
have available
everybody seems to love it and it seems
to be the most downloaded
product that is actually on my site so
if you do need some assistance and you
do want a guide to reference back
so that you know your drawings have all
the critical information that you need
it's been set up
as an international standard and an
international guide to help you
basically
draw better and document better the link
is down
there so check that one out and let's
get back to this video instead of going
back to the ground floor plan we're
going to go to our roof plan
double clicking will activate our roof
plan and right clicking on our ground
floor
show as trace reference is going to give
us our ground floor
plan underneath so we can see what's
actually going on
like i said to you before we're going to
be creating a concrete roof so instead
of going to the roof tool generically
so i'm going to go to the roof tool over
here i'm going to click the geometric
method over here
and then i'm going to reduce that to 0
degrees concrete roof
doesn't really have any fall in it it
twists and falls internally and has
drainage throughout but that's a whole
other topic what we want to do
is then select our construction method
going to the polygonal
one over here clicking once holding
shift
selecting which way we want our roof to
fall in this case it doesn't matter
because it's zero
and then holding shift dragging across
and
drawing a box so now as you see we have
our roof and it's completely hidden
out underneath layer normally there
would be a palette over here in my
default setup so what we want to do is
come across the window
come down to palettes and
then open up our re trace and reference
layer
so all i'm going to do now is drag and
drop that perfectly here
so we have our trace reference if we
want to see
underneath properly we can do our make
fills and zones transparent
so now we actually see right through our
floor plan and get a better
understanding
we can toggle on and off the trace layer
here as well by selecting that double
square what i want to do is
extend this roof by selecting offset
edge
i'm going to extend that 1500 and then
i'm also going to extend that 1500
the rear i'm going to extend 500 and the
side i'm also
going to extend 500 now that bit in
itself
isn't really too important but for the
time being
we're going to start by using it and
there we go we've created our flat
concrete roof as the wrong composite
so what we have at the moment is a
generic wall and shell
but all we're going to really go to is
user defined we're going to open up
those settings
we're going to go to custom let's say
that's about 150 millimeter concrete
roof slab
we're going to change the material
itself to concrete structural
and if we want to change the actual
texture of it
we can override all our surfaces and
paint that to concrete so over here we
have a whole bunch of different concrete
options let's go concrete light 23
selecting our link layer will change the
top material
the side and the underneath if for
example you didn't want that all
concrete we could open up our settings
again by clicking ctrl t
unlinking it going to our bottom layer
for example
let's type in timber what do we get we
have
wood mahogany let's go woodpine
horizontal and clicking
okay so it matches these sun shades over
here if we look at it now we have our
main concrete roof with some sort of
timber cladding underneath
now this roof would obviously get
thicker it would change as a composite
let's make that 200 mil
and increase the slab thickness oh sorry
not 2200
and we would see something along these
lines if we come back to our roof
structure
let's say we want to chop out a big
section of this roof to give it
just a little bit more depth we can
select one of these nodes
come to the subtract from polygon and we
can draw our own we can do a shape or we
can
do a rotated rectangle let's say we just
want to draw a basic square
right through the middle maybe i don't
know somewhere about there
then we can click on one of these sides
going to our offset edge
this is something i only learned quite
recently if we want to offset that
exactly 750 mil for example and we
didn't want to do the maths of 829 take
750
we can simply go 750 minus
okay we can do the same thing over here
let's say we want it to be 750 away 750
minus
gives us minus 33 then that's exactly
750 millimeters away from that wall
now what i want to do is curve these
edges like we did before
click the node chamfer fill it okay
and let's go back into our 3d to see
what we've just done
so now we've created these two
architectural pods one
swooping out on this left hand side and
the entry dragging it right in now i
don't
really like this entry i think it
definitely needs some sort of
phillips chamfer so we'll go 17 750
750 dragging that in doing the same
two meters over here coming back to 3d
see how that looks and we're just
getting a little bit of a different
architectural expression
coming into this house now now let's say
this house
needed a little bit extra we wanted a
blade wall we wanted something different
we wanted a nice brick feature so let's
click on this wall
let's go back to our materials and our
wall
options we have a whole bunch of
different wall options depends what kind
of
look you're really looking for you
probably don't need a 270 cavity brick
wall
you would be most likely going with a
one course face
brick so potentially we'll be selecting
this brick wall here
and let's drag a nice blade wall
in this case instead of going outside i
want centered
right through here let's drag that five
meters wide clicking ok
and going to our 3d so because i've
drawn that on that roof layer it's only
made that 250 millimeters tall
instead of the full length like i wanted
it to so what we can do is open up our
settings
go to the home story change that to
ground
go to the roof story change that to roof
and then that would usually be set to
zero but instead i wanted to
push past that roof so let's go another
750 above the roof
and there we have it now we have our
feature
brick wall coming all the way through
our concrete design
if we wanted to for example to cut that
wall
exactly around this concrete roof
what we could do is right click on the
roof go connect
solid element operations which gives us
a new pallet that allows us to change
things as we see fit so selecting now
the
wall as our target selecting the roof as
our operator and
then we want to subtract with
potentially an upwards extrusion
if we go execute we'll see it's cut off
everything above the roof if we click on
this square and select the x
it undoes all that now as a different
example we go select as target
select as operator subtract with
downwards extrusion and click ok
it cuts everything under that roof
now that might be exactly what you're
looking for as a blade wall
with a pathway through or it might not
be what you're looking for at all
now as you'll see here we've selected
the wrong brick wall
because that brick wall has a plaster
face instead what we want is actually
the cavity brick wall no plaster
so it's a double brick wall with no
actual
end now we definitely don't want to see
this cavity here so what we can do is
come back to our ground
go wall end tool click on that wall and
it will close up that gap
coming back into 3d you'll see it'll
create
not what we want so we right click to
open that up
it'll be a 3d representation of a
building material
so all we have to do is just change that
to brick structural
clicking ok and it will fix that right
up to how we need it to be
so we can do the exact same thing now by
going alt spinning around to the other
side of our brick wall clicking once
and it finishes off that wall quite
nicely
without us having to draw anything
further that is pretty much
finished but i don't like how that looks
so let's just quickly unclick that
and jump back into our ground floor plan
dragging this wall let's say
500 off that coming back into our 3d we
can see that blade wall
extends just slightly past so now we've
done a number of different features
we've created walls with curved walls
we've created windows and doors
we've created a concrete roof and we've
created a blade wall
with an enclosed end what we haven't
done is really worked with any timber
beams columns anything like that so
let's start by creating an
architectural feature screen let's jump
back into our ground floor plan
let's select our column tool and we'll
open up these settings
let's say we don't want a nice big 300
by 300 column
instead we want something like a
70 by 35 or even a 120 by 35
timber blade we definitely don't want
that
to stop 200 millimeters short of that
roof we want it to sit directly under
our roof and then if we come into our
segment options
we can see we can change it from a
generic structural
to a timber timber stud timber batten
over there and we can override all those
surfaces
and make it pine grained vertical
linking the two
what i want to do is basically wrap this
all the way around
over here so what we're going to do is
select
one of these clicking anywhere basically
to start creating that column
clicking control d allows us to move it
selecting the very end node and moving
it to our wall
let's space that 150 millimeters away
coming into our 3d you'll see we've
created our first
timber column that sits right at the
edge of
that roof structure now i think
personally i'd like to move that back
120 mil
so it sits a little bit away okay so now
if i wanted to create
some sort of easy method to wrap this
round and create a vertical screen what
we can do for the sake of argument is
simply click on our roof go
offset all edges click the control
button to duplicate that
and center it with our column over here
so now we have this secondary roof that
will delete later on
and we want to space that roughly 150 ml
apart
on 2.3 so let's say we want 16 copies of
this
we can simply click multiply we're going
to go drag distribute
16 copies go okay drag it all the way
over here
there's our 16th copy i'm going to
select that one as well and then go ctrl
g to group all of those together and now
to be able to actually understand the
fundamentals of this curve we're just
simply going to create
a circle that is the same radius
as that arc so now we can click on the
last column
click ok go multiply go to our rotate
spread 5 degrees rotate the path
which means it will rotate as that path
actually travels
we're going to find the center of our
circle which will automatically snap
so that's about there holding shift
clicking once
holding shift getting our 90 degrees
once again
ctrl g to group those i can delete that
roof
clicking that one there i can then once
again go multiply
drag distribute 16 copies one
clicking all the way up to about there
and then i can delete the secondary roof
we've created now if i go back to our 3d
we'll see a beautiful timber curved
feature
that wraps around that section of the
house now in reality that timber would
have to sit on something which means
we'd have to create some sort of beam
so if we come back to our beam tool go
all the way zoom in
open up our settings we can change that
to 120
wide by 35 actually we need that to be
35
tall and 120 wide because we're going
the other way
it then sits 0-0 on the ground it
doesn't link to any story
we're going to go segment we're going to
change that to timber stud
and we're going to open all these
settings link them
and make them pine grained now actually
thinking about it we do want to lift
this
35 millimeters off the ground so it is
sitting on the ground itself
we can then zoom in all the way select
the center
or the top of that first column go all
the way across
click once one more
click again and then just as we did
before
in creating that arch it's 1820
we can select that and it's a perfect
little
loop around so there we go we have our
timber beam
down the bottom created with a horrible
blue pen
so i'm going to select all those click
ok go to the floor plan segment
and override these blue lines
to black lines and there we go now we
have the bottom
chord of our timber feature we'll
probably also have a top chord
instead of bolting every single one
individually so we can click
ctrl d click on it once click control
again and drag a copy to the top
so now because we can see every single
one intersecting if we select
one of these columns click ctrl g we can
quickly select three of these groups and
i forgot to group this last one
this is exactly why we grip everything i
have to select
everything individually control g alt
g to be able to again activate this
stretch height tool and drop them all
35 millimeters and there we have it now
we have our timber feature
wrapping around with different uses of
columns
beams and arches in themselves as well
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below and don't
forget about the like button next to it
the like button helps this video with
the youtube algorithm
it helps this channel with the youtube
algorithm and it helps it grow
so if you did enjoy the video i would
truly appreciate it if you hit the like
button feel free to leave a comment down
below
ask me any question you wish i check as
many comments as i possibly can
and i reply to almost every single
person so whatever you might be thinking
feel free to leave it in the comments
down below
but anyway like always i will see you
next monday